[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana
en américa el espacio de france 24 donde
vamos a hablar de la pandemia en nuestro
continente yo soy madre clara calle y
estoy en reemplazo de santiago lópez que
está en una asignación de trabajo en el
programa de hoy hablaremos de que la
organización panamericana de la salud ya
ha distribuido más de 100 millones de
vacunas contra el cob y 19 en 33 países
de américa latina y el caribe esto a
través del mecanismo kóvacs al igual que
países como eeuu canadá o españa han
donado biológicos para que la ope se
suministre en la región en nuestra
consulta con el doctor pérez nuestro
asesor médico y científico analizaremos
porque no es igual contra el coronavirus
ya teniendo la vacuna que sin tenerla y
también les hablaremos de qué es la
inmunidad híbrida a propósito de los
recientes estudios que tratan este tema
y con nuestros corresponsales miraremos
cómo avanza la vacunación en mexico que
ya cumple un año de haber comenzado este
esquema en perú ya se reabrieron las
fronteras terrestres mientras que brasil
las muertes porque hoy 19 está
disparadas empecemos entonces esta
emisión mirando como avanzado la
pandemia de kobe 19 en las guayanas
ubicadas en el norte de suramérica estas
cifras son del conteo que llevó a la
universidad johns hopkins y comenzamos
en guyana allí los casos superan los 62
mil mientras que los fallecidos ya son
un poco más de 1200 en surinam estas
estadísticas aumentan pues se han
confirmado más de 77 mil casos positivos
y 1300 decesos a causa de la pandemia y
en la guayana francesa departamento de
ultramar francés se han reportado
alrededor de 77 mil contagios y 385
muertes por kobe 19 y ahora hablemos de
la vacunación en la región y hagámoslo
con una cifra 100 millones de dosis es
lo que la organización panamericana de
la salud ha distribuido en américa
latina y el caribe a través del
mecanismo kóvacs sin embargo la
cobertura sigue siendo muy desigual
100 millones de dosis de vacunas contra
el cob y 19 ese es el número de
biológicos que la organización
panamericana de la salud ha entregado a
los países de américa latina y el caribe
como parte de los esfuerzos conjuntos
con el mecanismo de distribución
internacional kóvacs con la finalidad de
que todo el mundo tenga acceso a la
inmunización de manera equitativa la
marca se alcanzó con la entrega de 151
mil 200 vacunas de la farmacéutica
moderna a haití y 1,5 millones de dosis
de facer a ecuador alrededor del 30 por
ciento del total de las vacunas fueron
donadas por eeuu canadá españa alemania
francia japón suecia noruega y dinamarca
aún así y karissa de tiempo la directora
de la organización panamericana de la
salud instó a no bajar la guardia
debemos recordar también la importancia
de dar de mantener medidas de salud
pública y sociales que funcionan a la
velocidad es indispensable porque esta
variante es prueba de lo rápidamente que
la situación puede cambiar y todavía
seguimos sintiendo el peso del omicron
según la opc esto porque a pesar de que
el 63 por ciento de la población de
américa latina y el caribe ha sido
vacunada contra el joven 19 la cobertura
sigue siendo desigual con 14 países y
territorios que aún no han inmunizado al
40 por ciento de su población
haití se mantiene como el país con menos
vacunación de la región con una tasa
inferior al 12 por ciento en comparación
con chile donde más del 88% de su
población total ha recibido el esquema
completo del fármaco según un estudio
realizado por estatista
en efecto el director de la organización
mundial de la salud insiste en la
necesidad de inocularse de akjout face
y
la fase aguda de esta pandemia terminará
este año por supuesto con una condición
es decir la vacunación del 70 por ciento
para mediados de este año alrededor de
junio julio y junio y eso es lo que
esperamos está en nuestras manos y por
eso decimos que no es una cuestión de
azar es una cuestión de elección
entonces si el mundo quiere acabar con
él tiene los medios para acabar con él
si quiere continuar siendo codicioso y
no quiere terminarlo entonces no
terminará entretanto la empresa alemana
beyond tech presentó su fábrica de
vacunas hecha con contenedores de envío
la cual planea enviar a áfrica como kits
de ensamblaje para que el continente
puede empezar a producir sus propias
vacunas de acá a unos 12 meses y ahora
saludo a esta hora al doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo y
nuestro asesor científico aquí en
france24 ella está con nosotros para
nuestra habitual consulta doctor pérez
como siempre es un gusto tenerlo y
comenzamos hablando de cuál es la
diferencia entre quienes contraen kobe
la vacuna y quienes no la tienen porque
hay estudios recientes que afirman que
quienes ya tienen esta inoculación se
demoran hasta cinco días en eliminar el
virus de sus cuerpos y quienes no la
tienen se puede demorar siete días o más
aparte de esta que otras diferencias hay
definitivamente las personas inmunizadas
es el mejor escenario porque en ese
escenario se disminuye como hablábamos
la probabilidad de transmitir el virus
en el tiempo pero además de eso en no
hay una manifestación clínica y también
que el alto de la carga viral lo
encontramos de virus sea mucha menor
cantidad y mucho menos efectiva el
contagio hacia otras personas esas están
dentro de las ventajas que hay de estar
vacunado y no estarlo y sobre todo
vacunados con refuerzo es mucho más
patente este estas buenas noticias que
el radio este tema que significa la
inmunidad híbrida porque quienes ya
contrajeron cobit y ya se vacunaron
además tienen cuatro veces menos de
posibilidades de ver una reinfección qué
significa este término
inmunidad de híbrida recordemos la
inmunidad vacunales cuando solo por
vacunas y no le ha dado la enfermedad la
inmunidad debilidad es que se enfermó y
luego se vacunó es decir que la primera
infección es como una vacuna y después
de eso se colocan la vacuna que
conocemos actualmente esa inmunidad
híbrida se ha mostrado que la inmunidad
es decir las defensas se mantienen más
tiempo y neutralizan más el virus que
las personas que solamente han decidido
vacunas y no han tenido kobe por eso si
una persona tiene cobit no tiene que
esperar nada sino vacunarse porque esa
dosis adicional después del código va a
ser mucho más efectiva que los que
solamente hemos recibido a un doctor y
ahora hablemos de la conexión entre kobe
19 y salud mental porque un estudio
reciente publicado en el british medical
journal afirma que quienes padecieron
con 19 tienen un 60% más probabilidades
de tener algún trastorno como depresión
o como ansiedad o incluso como ideas
suicidas cuál es esta conexión entre dos
estos dos temas entonces
es muy importante entender que el código
lo que hemos aprendido es que es una
inflamación sistémica es decir todo el
organismo se inflama dentro del cerebro
no es que todas las personas de covite
tengan estas patologías sino aquellas
personas que han tenido un qubit severo
que produce esa inflamación del pulmón
del corazón y del cerebro pueden tener
afectaciones neurológicas en
neuropsiquiátricas y lo que hemos visto
en pacientes con severo que están en una
fase de lyon joven es que la afectación
neurológica es muy importante
alteraciones de la memoria el
comportamiento del sueño y sobre todo en
pacientes que tienen infecciones severas
cuando una persona está vacunado no
tiene esas infecciones severas y mucho
menos chance de tener una complicación
neurológica por eso la importancia
vacunarse y ahora pasemos a otro tema
porque a medida que las mascarillas
siguen siendo obligatorias en muchos
países del mundo cada vez es más común
un término que es fatiga pandémica que
implica este término y qué significa
la fatiga pandémica es esta situación en
donde ya las medidas se empiezan a
relajarse simplemente porque las
personas quieren tener una dinámica
normal de su vida el uso los tapabocas
por ejemplo en espacios abiertos y
ventilados pues se está retirando en
varias partes del mundo guardando una
lógica que hay no hay muy poca
probabilidad de infección pero y
mantener los tapabocas el tener que
tener una disciplina social lleva a las
personas a que ésta no hagan caso y
estén practicando de estas instrucciones
y eso pudiera empeorar la situación por
la emergencia de otras variantes
importante vacunarse vacunarse con
refuerzo y cumplir las normas que hayan
en cada uno de los países acerca del uso
de la bioseguridad y ya pronto vamos a
salir de eso y terminamos esta consulta
con una pregunta acerca de una directriz
que dio la organización mundial de la
salud que aconsejó que quienes tengan un
contacto estrecho con alguien que haya
dado positivo ya no deben guardar una
cuarentena de 14 días sino de 7 que tan
efectiva esta medida doctor
sí ya desde hace un par de meses se está
reduciendo también una recomendación del
cs en eeuu de reducir los tiempos
estás cuarentenas y siete días parece
muy razonable qué es lo que hemos visto
con esta variante o micro es mucho más
impactante antes de iniciar los síntomas
y después del tercer al cuarto día cae
la carga viral es decir el número de
virus y prácticamente después del sexto
día no se encuentra y por eso después
del séptimo día las personas pueden
volver a sus actividades normales
entonces esa decisión que esto no es una
decisión basada en la evidencia y me
parece que es muy correctiva oportuna
que la implementamos en la energía
gracias doctor por explicarnos esta
evidencia científica que utiliza la ms y
ahora miremos qué está pasando con la
pandemia en eeuu allí hay un debate
público sobre si comenzar a levantar o
no las restricciones para contener el
brote cada vez más estados eliminan la
obligatoriedad de portar mascarillas en
espacios cerrados el que más
recientemente quitó esto fue california
pero otros estados que son
tradicionalmente demócratas que habían
tomado la misma decisión como lo
hicieron nueva jersey y delaware esto a
pesar de que el gobierno de joe biden ha
mantenido la recomendación de las
medidas
volver a la normalidad o seguir luchando
con restricciones contra el cob y 19 en
eeuu ese es el debate en la esfera
pública con un ojo mirando a los vecinos
de canadá y el miedo a que se imiten sus
protestas y con el otro mirando los
datos con más de 2.000 estadounidenses
muriendo cada día pero con una
disminución de los contagios en la
última semana de un 40 por ciento
respecto al anterior sobre ellos
reflexionó el miércoles anthony fauci el
asesor experto de la casa blanca de 10
no hay una solución perfecta para esto
se está tratando de equilibrar el hecho
de que el mundo y eeuu necesitan
recuperar su vida de alguna manera de
jess violín y eso ya no quiere ser
imprudente y tirar todo a un lado pero
tienes que empezar a avanzar hacia eso
por llegar story en hsinchu está ante
esto algunos estados como nueva jersey
connecticut delaware oregón y california
han levantado restricciones respecto a
las mascarillas en este último estado
desde el miércoles ya no tienen que
llevar el tapabocas en interiores
después de cerca de dos años de pandemia
hay quien celebra su nueva
obligatoriedad
[Risas]
ya era hora estoy listo para deshacerme
de ellas toca lidiar con ello como
lidiamos con la gripe y continuar volver
a vivir de nuevo
en
los centros para el control y la
prevención de enfermedades se están
empezando a revisar sus guías para el
cob y 19 aunque aseguran que los cambios
se basarán en datos y ciencia vuelta
paulatina a la normalidad sí pero con
precaución en el país más castigado por
la pandemia con más de 900 mil muertos
por el virus y seguimos en norteamérica
porque méxico cumplió un año desde que
comenzó su programa de vacunación contra
el coronavirus en medio de una
disminución de los contagios vamos a la
ciudad de méxico donde está nuestro
corresponsal mario carbonell mario
bienvenido de nuevo al programa comí 19
la semana en américa y empezamos
hablando precisamente de este
aniversario que tan extendido está este
programa de vacunación y que tantas
personas se ha alcanzado
así es un año ya de aplicación masiva de
vacunas en mexico y a la fecha se han
aplicado alrededor de 175 millones de
dosis a cerca de 85 millones de personas
de las cuales 93 por ciento tienen ya el
su esquema completo esto de acuerdo con
la secretaria de salud sin embargo la
organización panamericana de la salud ha
señalado que en méxico país de 126
millones de habitantes es
60% la cantidad que ha recibido su
esquema completo únicamente y esto bueno
en parte a que el gobierno se ha
rehusado a inocular a la población
infantil con el argumento de que el
riesgo en los niños es muy bajo y por
ello no son población prioritaria para
el programa de vacunación actualmente el
país está aplicando tercera dosis o
dosis de refuerzo a población de entre
30 y 39 años aunque en la ciudad de
mexico que es sin duda la más avanzada
en vacunación se anunció ya para la
próxima semana la dosis de refuerzo para
los jóvenes de entre 10 y 29 años de
edad con lo que se estaría cumpliendo ya
con el total de la población adulta con
tres dosis anti kobe de la capital del
país mario y además de la vacuna otra de
las noticias son los contagios de kobe
19 porque en méxico comenzaron a
disminuir después de que ese país
atravesará el peor momento de la cuarta
ola a finales de enero
en este sentido entonces cuál es el
panorama del virus y qué tantos casos
hay
efectivamente las autoridades sanitarias
se reportan una reducción de 48 por
ciento en esta cuarta ola y la
incidencia de casos nuevos se ubica por
debajo de lo que se tuvo en olas previas
a la organización panamericana de la
salud señaló esta semana que en méxico
hay una reducción de 62 por ciento en
los casos activos durante las últimas
tres semanas no obstante bueno llamaron
a la organización llamó a no confiarse
porque esta tendencia a la baja podría
eventualmente modificarse en cualquier
momento el subsecretario de salud y
responsable para el manejo de la
pandemia hugo lópez gatell ha dicho que
literalmente se están vaciando las
unidades kobe en el país y en la ciudad
de mexico de nueva cuenta se reporta una
reducción de hasta 80 por ciento en
casos positivos respecto del máximo que
se tuvo el pasado 17 de enero
y ahora recordemos algo porque a finales
del 2020 del presidente de andrés manuel
lópez obrador dijo que méxico iba a
tener su propia vacuna y que ésta se
llamaría patria y además afirmó que la
tendrían lista para el 2021 sin embargo
se acabó este año y la vacuna todavía no
está explíquenos en qué va este
biológico y su producción y su
aprobación en mexico
bueno en cuanto a la vacuna patria el
consejo nacional de ciencia y tecnología
señaló recientemente que demostró ser
eficaz para uso humano y que tiene un
potencial inmunológico está esta vacuna
llamada patria esto de acuerdo con los
resultados de la fase 1 de ensayos
clínicos en la que participaron 90
voluntarios que no habían recibido
ningún tipo de vacuna actualmente se
lanzó ya la convocatoria para la fase 2
de estudios clínicos para lo que se
requiere la participación de 400
voluntarios que hayan tenido ya su
esquema completo con al menos cuatro
meses de anterioridad con así también
señaló que podría eventualmente
utilizarse la vacuna patria como una
dosis de refuerzo para en los esquemas
con otras vacunas y que podría aplicarse
vía intramuscular o incluso por la nariz
es decir mientras nasal
hay que recordar que el presidente lópez
obrador confió en que el año pasado a
diciembre de 2021 ya estaría aplicando
cosas que bueno no ha sido así a pesar
de la inversión que se anunció de 9
millones de dólares para el desarrollo
de este proyecto a cargo de laboratorios
avimex
bueno mario quedaremos atentos a qué
pasa con esta vacuna patria de mexico y
nos movemos a canadá porque allí
continúan las manifestaciones a pesar de
la ley de emergencias que invocó el
primer ministro georges team trudeau los
camioneros que cruzan la frontera con
eeuu se oponen a la vacunación que es
obligatoria para ellos o que los obliga
a guardar cuarentena
al son de música bailes luces y bocinas
a pesar de estar prohibido por orden
judicial
400 vehículos y cientos de personas en
oposición a los mandatos de vacuna
contra el cob y 19 se dieron cita frente
al parlamento de canadá haciendo caso
omiso a la ley de emergencias invocada
por el primer ministro canadiense josh
instruido una medida que le permite a
las autoridades incautar los vehículos
de las protestas y procesar a quienes
viajen a la capital para sumarse al
bloqueo en efecto el jefe interino de la
policía de ottawa quien asumió el cargo
hace unos días tras la dimisión de
peters loli después de fuertes críticas
por el manejo del bloqueo advirtió en
acción' en los últimos días nos hemos
estado comunicando directamente con los
manifestantes ilegales les hemos dicho
que deben irse y les hemos advertido las
consecuencias de desobedecer estas
reglas
como por ejemplo enfrentarse a multas
cárcel o la confiscación de sus
licencias de conducir amenazas que
ayudaron a convencer a los camioneros a
retirarse de cuatro puntos fronterizos
de eeuu incluido el puente ambassador
que juega un papel crucial en las
economías de ambos países
conforme se aumentó la presencia
policial se empezaron a realizar algunos
arrestos entre ellos el de dos de los
principales organizadores y recaudadores
de fondos del llamado convoy de la
libertad también se restringió el acceso
al centro de ottawa mientras que los
agentes comenzaron a levantar barreras
alrededor de los edificios
gubernamentales
medidas que no fueron bien recibidas por
los manifestantes
esta acumulación simboliza operaciones
ilegales órdenes ilegales ya que esta no
es una ley de emergencia en este momento
no está vigente tiene que pasar por dos
niveles más en el parlamento puedan
actuar sobre eso están actuando
ilegalmente actúan bajo órdenes ilícitas
pero el primer ministro no contempla dar
su brazo a torcer y se siente respaldado
porque según un estudio realizado por la
organización our world in that a 4 de
cada 5 canadienses están vacunados
contra el coronavirus es decir el 80 por
ciento de su población total que cuenta
con más de 38 millones de habitantes a
esto se suma que el 90% de camioneros en
territorio canadiense está protegido
contra el virus según la canadian
tracking lines y el 45 por ciento de la
población del país está a favor de las
medidas impuestas para afrontar la
pandemia de acuerdo a la más reciente
encuesta del instituto canadiense angus
ritz
brevemente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente pero en mente les
cuento que desde el 17 de febrero
república dominicana suspendió las
restricciones de kobe 19 ahora los
habitantes no tienen que portar
mascarilla de manera obligatoria y tiene
que mostrar su carnet de vacunación para
poder entrar a los lugares públicos y
brevemente también les comento que la
principal causa de muerte en colombia es
el co bit 19 según el departamento
administrativo nacional de estadísticas
del dane
hubo casi 80.000 muertos por corona
virus entre enero y octubre de 2021 y
también esto es más que los cerca de
50.000 fallecimientos por corona virus
que se confirmaron en el 2020 y
terminamos este breve recorrido en perú
la autoridad de medicamentos el digemid
aprobó el uso del molde pyramid que es
la pastilla que desarrolló el
laboratorio merck para tratar el
coronavirus será para los pacientes que
tienen alto riesgo de enfermedades y
será necesario tener una fórmula médica
para poder comprar este fármaco y
seguimos en suramérica porque el
gobierno de perú liderado por pedro
castillo autorizó de nuevo que se abran
las fronteras terrestres este es un hito
importante para el país pues cerca de 40
por ciento de los turistas llegan a
través de las vías que conectan a esta
nación con chile y con ecuador para
hablar de esto está con nosotros
francisco zacarías desde lima francisco
bienvenido de nuevo a nuestro programa y
empecemos hablando de cómo se está dando
esa reapertura de fronteras
hola maría clara el descenso de caso
seco y 19 registrado en las últimas
semanas y el incremento de vacunados
motivaron a las autoridades peruanas a
abrir las fronteras terrestres a más de
un mes de cumplirse dos años del cierre
obligado por la pandemia el sars cop 2
es una buena noticia para la integración
de perú con sus países vecinos porque
también se reactivan el comercio y el
turismo los pueblos fronterizos están
más que contentos porque se dinamizará
la economía el requisito principal para
el ingreso a territorio peruano es la
presentación de la constancia del
esquema completo de vacunación contra el
jove 19 y así quedó abierto el tránsito
terrestre de perú con bolivia brasil y
ecuador con colombia se implementan
acciones para la reapertura de fronteras
el único país que queda rezagado en esta
apertura de límites es chile la nación
sureña decidió militarizar su frontera
con perú para controlar la migración
irregular de ciudadanos venezolanos en
su territorio las autoridades chilenas
decretaron el estado de excepción por 15
días en sus bordes con bolivia y perú
que pueden extenderse por otros 15 días
más
francisco y una de las noticias
específicamente en lima es que las
autoridades desplegaron un cerco
epidemiológico porque encontraron los
contagios particulares de covite 19
explíquenos a qué se debe esto y qué
hicieron las autoridades en ese cerco
las autoridades sanitarias tras haber
detectado tres casos del sub linaje ba2
de omicron aplican un cerco
epidemiológico en los distritos de lima
brigadas de salud realizan pruebas de
descarte para casa por casa en un
barrido para evitar una eventual
propagación de la su variante en ese
país la denominada ahijado micrón fue
hallada en una señora de 91 años y su
hijo de 61 años adicionalmente la
universidad peruana cayetano heredia
también reportó otro caso encontrado por
su laboratorio ninguno de los infectados
había sido inmunizado los expertos
locales afirman que ve a dos es
transmisible pero no generaría otro pico
de contagios sin embargo las autoridades
despliegan logística y profesionales
para acortar las brechas de vacunación
de la tercera dosis contra el hobbit 19
el ministro de salud hernán condori
sostiene que a diferencia de la primera
y segunda ola la tercera etapa de la
pandemia ha ocasionado menos fallecidos
porque la mayor parte de la población
está vacunada
y precisamente como usted lo mencionó
las vacunas son la medida que el
gobierno está utilizando para hacerle
frente a la pandemia y en este tema una
de las novedades es que ya el 28% de la
población objeto de esta vacuna contra
el joven 19 en perú obtuvo la dosis de
refuerzo francisco que otros datos
tenemos y cómo va esa vacunación en perú
en todo el perú de la campaña de
vacunación ha aplicado más de 60
millones de dosis lo que representa el
72 por ciento de la población objetivo
con dos dosis y esto constituye
alrededor de 24 millones de personas de
las cuales más de 9,4 millones ya tiene
la tercera dosis de refuerzo al respecto
del primer ministro aníbal torres
anunció que volverán las jornadas de
vacunación de 24 horas en algunas fechas
el gobierno de pedro castillo quiere que
los peruanos estén vacunados para
flexibilizar las restricciones y reabrir
el país plenamente las autoridades saben
que sólo así se podrá reactivar en su
totalidad las actividades productivas
dinamizar la economía y generar más
puestos de trabajo gracias francisco por
este reporte y nosotros seguimos con
cómo ha avanzado la vacunación en el
continente americano en esta oportunidad
les presentamos los países de la región
que más vacunas aplicadas llevan según
su porcentaje de población cuba lidera
la lista en américa pues el 94 por
ciento de su población ya está
totalmente inoculada según las cifras
oficiales
el 87% tiene el esquema completo aunque
las dosis suministradas en ese país son
las que se produjeron en la isla y que
aún no tienen la aprobación de la ong en
chile del 92% de las personas ya se
inoculó incluyendo al 89 por ciento que
tienen todas las dosis necesarias y le
sigue argentina con el 88 por ciento de
los habitantes que tienen al menos una
dosis estos países están incluso por
encima de los porcentajes de vacunación
de eeuu y canadá a pesar de que la
vacunación avanzada en la región la
pandemia todavía no retrocede y en
países como costa rica y brasil
decidieron hacerle un homenaje a los
fallecidos
la fundación costarricense sant ramon
carbono neutral está promoviendo la
iniciativa healing trees que aspira a
que se siembren 6 millones de árboles en
honor a las víctimas que deja la
pandemia mientras que en brasil el
senado inauguró un memorial que tiene 27
prismas de mármol y dedican una un por
cada estado del país
otra de las noticias en brasil es que
allí están aumentando las muertes
diarias provocadas por el coronavirus el
gigante sudamericano enfrenta una nueva
ola de decesos que ha habido días en los
que superan los 1000 diarios aunque
todavía es una cifra que está lejos de
lo que se vivió en abril de 2021 y para
hablar de esto conectamos con río de
janeiro donde está nuestra corresponsal
valeria saccone valeria bienvenida a
nuestro programa y empecemos hablando de
cuál es la causa detrás del repunte de
estos fallecimientos y qué tan grave es
la situación epidemiológica y también
háblenos un poco de la vacunación
brasil registra los peores datos de
muertes y contagios por el coronavirus
de los últimos seis meses la media
semanal se sitúa en 800 muertos por día
con picos de más de 1000 muertos y
también los contagios llevan más de 10
días por encima de los 100 mil casos
nuevos diarios
brasilia perdidos 640 mil vidas por casa
del coronavirus y está esperando que
pase esta nueva ola de contagios causada
por la variante omicron 6 que el pico
sea a final de febrero y después las
cosas lentamente deberían empezar a
mejorar de hecho la curva de contagios y
de muertes por primera vez en semanas
empieza a estabilizarse después de haber
subido de forma ininterrumpida durante
35 días la buena noticia que en brasil
tiene buenos datos de vacunación el 71%
de la población ya tiene las dos dosis
de la vacuna y el 27% ya recibió la
dosis de refuerzo y además de la
vacunación existe la posibilidad de que
en brasil se distribuya el medicamento
contra el cob y 19 específicamente estoy
hablando del que hace la farmacéutica
pfiezer pues este laboratorio le pidió a
brasil y específicamente a la agencia
nacional de vigilancia sanitaria que
aprobara el uso del pax lobby de valeri
explíquenos que se sabe de esto y que ha
habido y que negociaciones ha habido
entre el gobierno y fisher
la agencia brasileña de vigilancia
sanitaria anvisa recibió esta semana una
petición por parte de la farmacéutica
pfiezer para autorizar el uso de
carácter de emergencia de pax loving el
nuevo antiviral que ha sido desarrollado
para tratar los síntomas del coni 19
ahora la visa tiene un plazo de 30 días
para analizar toda la documentación que
ha sido presentada por facer que en sus
datos dice que puede reducir las
hospitalizaciones y las muertes por
coronavirus hasta en un 89% eso sí esta
farmacéutica recuerda que ese antiviral
no es una alternativa a la vacuna que es
importante seguir vacunándose y que este
medicamento puede servir para paliar los
síntomas o bien para aquellas personas
que no quisieron vacunarse o bien para
personas que a pesar de la vacunación
contrajeron el virus y en un campo más
político también hay noticias de la
pandemia porque la justicia le pidió al
gobierno de jair bolsonaro que
corrigiera unas directrices que
desincentivaba en la vacunación en la
población entre 5
hace años en qué consiste esta decisión
judicial
un juez de la corte suprema de brasil ha
instado dos ministros del gobierno de
jair bolsonaro a que revisen unas
directrices que estarían dificultando la
vacunación infantil la polémica se
remonta al mes de diciembre cuando un
largo debate sobre la vacunación de
niños de entre 5 y 11 años es un asunto
espinoso y el propio presidente ya eres
bolsonaro se declaró contrario
públicamente a la vacunación de los
niños sin embargo la vacunación empezó y
entonces dos ministros de salud y de la
familia habilitando un canal para que
padres que no están de acuerdo con esta
decisión puedan quejarse por la
exigencia del pasaporte de la vacuna sin
embargo este canal fue creado
originariamente para recoger denuncias
contra violaciones de derechos humanos y
por eso el juez lewandowski del supremo-
ha dicho que se trata de un uso indebido
de este canal este revés para jair
bolsonaro por parte del supremo llega en
un momento de mucha atención entre
ejecutivo judiciario recordamos que el
supremo está investigando ya él
bolsonaro por varias razones entre ellas
diseminar noticias falsas y atacar las
instituciones democráticas gracias
valeria y sigamos con un vistazo sobre
cuáles son las variantes predominantes
en diferentes países de américa
empezamos en las naciones
centroamericanas concretamente en
guatemala allí el linaje delta es el que
se ha detectado en más del 97% de los
casos confirmados en las últimas dos
semanas mientras que otras variantes
representan un poco menos del 3% en
costa rica prevalece omicron con el 100
por ciento de los contagios y terminamos
en las antillas con curazao donde
omicron llega al 89 5% y delta
corresponde al 10,5 por ciento
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 destacadas en redes
sociales y es que todos los menores
entre 5 y 11 años en honduras ya se
pueden vacunar contra el coronavirus
este país centroamericano ya había
empezado el programa de vacunación en
esa población pero antes estaba dirigida
únicamente a los niños y niñas que
padecieran inmunosupresión ahora todos
los menores pueden inocular si luego de
que el gobierno comprará vacunas para
1,3 millones de niños y en ecuador' el
administrativo está considerando
levantar la obligatoriedad de
mascarillas en los lugares abiertos la
ministra de salud jimena garzón estimó
que entre abril y mayo podría darse ese
relajamiento de las medidas pero todo
depende de si la positividad viral logra
reducirse y quedar por debajo de un 5
por ciento esto es el porcentaje de
casos positivos que se detectan cada 100
pruebas que se toman y también les
cuento que en paraguay se aplicará una
nueva vacuna contra el coronavirus se
trata de la inoculación de dos dosis que
desarrolló el laboratorio me dije en de
taiwán la aprobación de uso se dio luego
de que en el país suramericano se
superarán las tres fases de estudios
clínicos esta es la misma vacuna que en
taiwán se utiliza como dosis de refuerzo
aunque todavía no aparece en el listado
de los esquemas que la ms ya aprobó
y así llegamos al final de nuestro
resumen semanal de cómo avanza la
pandemia de kobe 19 en américa es un
gusto haber estado con ustedes y los
invito a que consulten más en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom nos vemos
[Música]